okay we're going to move on to our
second subject now because here the
environment agency's chief has given us
a stark warning saying we must adapt or
die when it comes to dealing with
extreme weather brought about by climate
change and similar language has been
used by world leaders and environmental
groups to shock people into action but
does it always work mikhail to you first
of all i'm just going to put a statistic
to you apparently 56 of young people
think that humanity is doomed so
should we talk in these kind of terms
does it frighten people and put people
off the climate change cause or does it
prompt people to take action
we need to do both
we need to make sure that everyone is
aware that we are in a place and in a
time that we need to act right now
and unfortunately being in the comfort
zone and telling us no you know what
everything is fine and you just have to
use some plastic straws and everything
will be fine that's not going to cut it
and we know that so we need to describe
reality as it is in reality as it is is
pretty scary but if we stop there
that's not going to take us anywhere so
the next thing that we have to do is be
angry about it a little bit and it's um
and we need to be angry because we did
this and we made decisions along the way
the collectively that led to this
but if we stop there that's not good
enough either because right the next
step that we need to take is agency
and everything in all the science and
all the ipcc reports and everything that
we know teaches us and tells us that we
still can make a difference
so we take this um
sadness and we take this anger and we
channel it into agency that's where we
need to go so adapt or die is exactly a
call for action it is um if we don't
then we will uh suffer great
circumstances but we can okay michael
what do you think a message of fear or
message of hope what works best
i think mccall you know uh spelled it
out right here um it's urgency and
agency yes we're already facing
devastating consequences of human-caused
climate change and it will get much
worse if we fail to take action that's
the urgency we can see the urgency we're
literally seeing the the you know the
the dangerous and damaging impacts of
climate change play out in real time now
that's the urgency the agency as mccall
says we have time to prevent the worst
it's going to be a monumental challenge
and cop 26 is where we have to make it
happen this is our moment if we are
going to keep warming uh to a level that
we can still adapt to that will remain
within our adaptive capacity we need to
see substantial action now and that's
what cop26 has to be about okay we will
leave it on that note with mikhail
nodding mikhail michael good to see you
both thanks very much indeed
you